[Music]
how are you guys doing how are you doing
I'm doing very good fantastic to see you
yes must be must
be okay before we start guys um we're
all doing this a charity project and
this for one isn't it yes and I've got
the link below this is Ramadan it's a
special time it's a time whereby if you
give in charity it will be multiplied um
manifold it will be be something which
should be on your skills and their
judgment and what we're doing now is
actually an
emergency um is it the Food Packs no not
the Food Packs so we've done the Food
Packs the first 10 days this is now
getting to the juice of it we're talking
about the emergency packs the emergency
aid to the people of Gaza yes the people
of Gaza and even the people of Sudan and
other countries where their emergencies
are happening SP this interesting the
word emergency if you look in Google it
means a situation where it needs
immediate action it need attention so we
look that out no no no I always have it
you know cuz I'm I'm studying with the
champ no so this is very important
because when we say emergency people
don't really understand it's something
that requ immed understand the word they
don't they don't they become this is the
most useless contribution you're making
no it is something bro you can save
someone's life you know Allah says
in whoever saves the life it's like
saving all of humanity exactly like
situation is also emerg it is urgent
attention psychologic I'm hon you Define
psychologically
Al so just just as a preamble to the
video this is a very important thing and
it will only take you a couple of
seconds and it will increase your your
Deeds on the day of judgment it'll be an
amazing thing so please click the button
below look I wanted to give you
something uh to to react to actually
who's it who's it about it was about
Candace Owens and she was having this
conversation with she must be really
happy at the daily wire isn't she is she
having a successful career everyone
knows that she was fired by a daily wire
and The Masks have dropped I thought
they were about freedom of speech though
they're not about freedom of speech
they're about selective freedom of
speech we know this now we know this
they're a pro Zionist organization if
you don't tow the party line with them
then they'll fire you and this is a
great experiment in fact it's one of the
their worst moments because everyone can
see it now they only had one black woman
of color and they got rid of her now
isn't it and she used to say Christ is
King and
she is there another black woman in
there as well I don't know I don't think
so oh there isn't no well not at that
level anyway it's a pret they may be in
the background or working somewhere else
to even have a black woman that I
believe is it was intentionally done now
they're like oh it doesn't serve us you
know it's and guess what they are people
who are against objective news they're
saying objective news is pro
Hamas can you imagine if objective news
is pro Hammer then you're finish it
Candace Owens is is proam I'll tell you
what talking about Candace Owens she had
this conversation with this guy called
Rabbi Bley we both know we all know R
Who barley h no not HSBC but barlay we
we know how she's been having back come
forth with Unholy schoy yeah okay that
guy's a creep bro what a dirty filthy
you guys should see my video on that
what weirdo but then it's now she had
this conversation with barklay and she
he's obviously been slandering her and
stuff and um and one thing I will say to
Candace ens if she's watching and I do
have reason to believe that she'll be
watching a video like this is um yes
it's it's important sometimes to defend
yourself from the slanderers we've all
been slandered in our time in public
life but don't give it too much
attention because frankly the their
appetite is insatiable their appetite is
insatiable and whatever you say will not
be enough for them and these guys have
already got preconceived notions I want
I say these guys I'm talking about
zionists who have these kind of belief
systems but talking about zionists with
incredibly despicable and heus belief
systems I want to just show you a clip
and it's just a very short short clip of
what this man says barklay it can't get
worse can it's I was absolutely GoBack
that we've seen at they' it's wor it's
shocking I want to see let's take a look
at it I want to see this do you think it
is sad when an innocent Palestinian
child
dies Candice I cry every day and it's
not just for
Israel and this is one of the things you
clearly do not understand the same when
most don't are anti-em you don't get it
I cry for what's going on in Israel I
Cry Just just as much for what we are
forced to
do golden Meer had a great
quote she said that one day we may be
able to forgive them for killing Israeli
children we will never be able to
forgive them for making them making us
kill their
children what about my statement of
saying that I also cry for Palestinian
children is wrong to you if you also
admit it is sad and Palestinian children
die it's painful but it is not in any
way shape or form morally equivalent to
October 7th now there's a lot of
nonsense that this guy was saying
throughout the interview but let's just
let's just focus on this what on Earth
what on Earth is this this is psych this
is psychopathic you know you know it's
like a rapist raping somebody and saying
you know what you're making me do this
that's BR in any society you think that
person is sick a weirdo you know just
psychologically messed up and this is
what Israel is sh itself to be you said
it's interesting it's like imagine
you're raping someone and then you're
saying I'm more Angry for the fact that
you're making me do this yeah can you
imagine you're saying I'm blaming you
for what I'm doing to you and I'm angry
for you making me do that no but the
thing is the same exact logic
gaslighting bro gaslighting at its
finest Well it's worse than that I tell
you what I mean let me tell you
something right if this logic will be
were to be extended yeah one could say
the same thing about October 7th yeah
they they so okay why did uh and we we
don't take for granted and we've already
refuted these claims about the 40
beheaded babies and stuff like that so
if there were civilians that were killed
or Hamas turns around and says well uh
we will never forgive you for letting us
do this killing making us do this and
we've already refuted those claims and
they have more right to their logic to
say that because this been going for
about 75 years I mean it's absolutely
it's despicable it's shocking I'm
actually quite disappointed in Candace I
have to say because instead of focusing
on this low laying intellectual fruit
which she could have just batted out of
the uh Arena she started defending
herself again and this is now becoming a
bit pathological Candace I'll be honest
with you you you have a man here saying
we'll never forgive them for what
they've done to us which is make them
kill their children and you're focusing
on what I said and what he said exactly
frankly that's not what you should be
focusing on as a black woman when we
look at history what happened to the uh
the black people like King leopo II what
did in Congo killing 10 million people
imagine him coming and saying I am more
angry with you C this for making me do
this to the congales like and imagine
how would your reaction be would you be
talking about yourself or defending
yourself or letting this comment pass by
you wouldn't and look how he's casually
dehumanizing the children and not only
that what he said is absolutely you have
to be psychologically unwell yeah I
think I I I agree with you guys 100%
regardless of the situation with what's
going on in Palestine you have to stand
up for the Palestinians it's it's about
being on the right side of History
however I can see uh and it's in
interesting to kind of look at the
dynamic here maybe she may have
understood that these her these are her
dying moments in Daily wire that maybe
you know she can get back some of her
reputation or she was gagged or you know
she was yeah but and and there are
certain announcements to to suggest that
maybe now that she's got her own
platform that we are going to see a
completely uncensored version where we
see reality so we hopeful yes well I
like the way You' said that because we
want to give everyone a chance I mean
she obviously is not a psychopath she's
seen what's happened with the children
she's a mother herself she was pregnant
I think at one point and she can
empathize with these and sympathize with
these people just like any human being
with decency would be able to do okay
but let call a spade a spade for a
second it doesn't matter where you're
working or where you're getting your
paycheck if you're seeing someone say
right that we will never forgive you for
forcing us to kill your children I'm
sorry that kind of statement cannot go
unchecked I'm sorry to say and for for
it to just kind of be moved to the side
because let's focus on the bigger isue
at hand which is what which is my
reputation in the case of Candace in
this case I think it's problematic
frankly it is but I will say that this
is now it's it's reached a stage where
after I read I I listened to this and I
saw him say that I was like there's no
there there's no reasoning with this
kind of person you can't there's no
reasoning with this kind of person it's
not it's not it's unbelievable average
individual watching this and hearing
these people speak on a day-to-day basis
it just gets worse and worse and more
disgusting more disturbing more
gaslighting it's it's really really
disturbing and a lot more people are
waking up and I think Candace Owens
being a Christian herself and and seeing
the contempt towards Christianity as
well and she's mentioned a lot of posts
as well where she's saying that the that
the bowl has been spiked and that's why
we're seeing Christ being um you know
mocked in Hollywood and she's she's
saying a lot of interesting stuff and
hopefully through her leaving now she'll
be able to say more things that will
awaken more people because it seems like
it's not working when it's coming from
people like us maybe it will come from
you know their own I think we're going
to see the real Candace Owens once she
has her own platform we're going to see
what she's really about cuz now the
daily wire influence that is not there
but alhamdulillah you know what it is
like Allah you know when we told will
speak out I just feel like you know
what's happening now with the Zionist
they are literally showing the whole
world the true reality with their own
tongue you cannot make this up W you
cannot if you orchestrated it nobody
will put a script down even if we
Muslims were scripting we never put a
script down as bad as this no cuz
imagine that imagine if I went to PE
Morgan show and he asked me about
October the 7th and I said look uh yeah
I mean they the 40 babies were killed
for the sake of argument I but they made
us kill him they'll be on front pages BR
I'll be angry you'll be in prison br
it's a prison offense I yeah 100% it's
definitely a criminal offense and even
here in the UK there was that image of a
child on the Jewish holy day going with
a replica gun oh yeah I'm going on the
streets I'm going to go to that street
and then the and the Hackney police
responded by saying oh it's not really
an offense what so we can around but if
my son dressed up in Isis and went with
a
gun look it's it's incredible double
standards and it's untenable at this
stage but what we will say is we have a
chance to do our bit by spreading videos
like this but also by clicking the link
below and helping our brothers and
sisters in in Gaza in Sudan in different
parts in Afghanistan where emergency aid
is required let's be people of action
honestly any last words guys no that's
it and don't forget to support uh threat
like any Last Words My Last Words will
be in support the charity the charity
brother sister and my last words would
be to live by it to die by
it
for